joining us now the author of saving nine
that's utah senator mike lee uh senator
uh you're one of the few people that i
know that really cares about our
constitution i give you a lot of credit
we did reveal it was revealed during
these hearings that jamie raskin has an
another
uh motive in all of this he wants to get
rid of that outdated relic called the
u.s constitution
that calls for
uh
the electors to end up picking the
president uh that's interesting to me
because that would mean that liz
cheney's father never would have been
elected vice president
the electoral college he wants to remind
me and
yeah he wants to eliminate the electoral
college which is about as fundamental to
our system of government as it comes
there's no way around this look uh the
us constitution has fostered the
development of the greatest civilization
the world has ever known for reasons
that escape astound and dismay me the
modern democratic party wants to throw
it under the bus they want to throw it
under the bus with statements like that
that he's making they want to throw it
under the bus by intimidating
denigrating and demeaning the supreme
court of the united states and
ultimately by packing the court so they
can turn it into a political football
and sean the thing is without the
supreme court being an independent
arbiter of what the law is there is no
constitution they want to pack it so
they can destroy the court and in so
doing destroy the constitution that's
why i wrote saving nine saving nine
tells the story of the last time this
happened in the fact that we're still
paying the price for it
when you look at for example just
abolishing the electoral college or
packing the courts or
statehood for d.c or getting rid of the
filibuster all these items the democrats
have bought up brought up um and your
book really does highlight the
importance of the supreme court
when they do this the democrats have
always wanted to do things that they can
never get done at the ballot box or can
never get done
in congress legislatively and they want
the courts to do their job for them and
legislate from the bench uh that's not
particularly good for our country is it
no it's terrible for our country and it
doesn't work out well for anyone
sometimes for them it works out in in
the short term but in the long term it
hurts everyone including and especially
them
but look if they attempt this again if
they try to pack the supreme court again
unlike 1937 i tell the story in saving
nine uh of how franklin d roosevelt who
is sort of a hero a role model an idol
if you will to joe biden he tried to do
this back in 1937. it failed in part
because there were a lot of democrats
who were willing to stand up to the
democratic president at the time we
don't have that today nor do we have the
the buffer uh that that we had back in
1937 but as i explained in 19
in saving nine back in 1937 even though
it failed legislatively
it coerced the supreme court to switch
its view of a particular provision of
the constitution
and that reading that reinterpretation
was a de facto amendment of the
constitution
that has caused the federal government
to become too big too expensive and too
far-reaching we're paying for it ever
since then so look all these efforts to
denigrate the constitution and our
system
you can draw a consistent thread between
the statements of jamie raskin the
efforts to protest outside supreme court
justices homes efforts to assassinate
supreme court justices and the refusal
of the president of the united states to
condemn going to supreme court justices
homes to protest in front of them to
harass them to try to get to them to
change their ruling in a case that is
wrong and it's it's counter to
everything we believe in about
constitutional government
you know it's amazing to me that the
white house gave their tacit approval
and actually encouraged in the case of
jansaki the doxings of these supreme
court justices homes uh you know the
tape of schumer you know you better
listen to me gorsuch you better listen
to me kavanaugh uh you won't know what
hit you uh that sounded like a threat to
me um if i made a threat to a supreme
court justice would i be committing a
crime
yes yes you would and you would
especially be committing a crime if you
were going to the supreme court
justice's homes to protest in front of
them and if you're the president of the
united states who actively encourages
people to do that
and through your press secretary jenn
saki
if you said yes i support this you'd be
actively encouraging that we know he
encourages it and we know therefore that
he is trying to pack the court we've got
to stop him now and that's why i
encourage people to read saving nine it
will give them the tools necessary to
confront this
as many people as possible to read it so
that they're ready to respond we need
the help of all americans on this issue
all right the book is called saving nine
uh i couldn't be a more timely book
senator mike lee thank you for being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else